non-minimalists
about your transition out of the
the corporate world what was that
decision like
for you and i think back to when
i started as a freelancer and
it sounds similar to you guys where you
say you had 50
followers come to your site 50 people
come to your site to
read what you had to say um i had a 100
project every once in a while every two
weeks not enough
right 50 people is likely not enough
um if you're trying to to spread your
message message
and make a sustainable thing yeah to
make it yeah to
to uh to have people to support you yeah
yeah absolutely i mean again we never
had a number
in our heads on like how many people i
mean in fact if you were to ask me now
like
so what's the number to have a
sustainable
audience uh that can uh support you on a
consistent basis like i wouldn't even be
able to tell you
um yeah and it's probably different for
everyone because yeah some people with
f50 if you're
a really well-known artist and you have
50 really good buyers
you might be a multi-millionaire yeah um
uh very true
or if uh you know kevin kelly says you
know a thousand true fans or whatever
i think ryan early on you and i we
weren't
it wasn't a business though like
literally it legitimately wasn't a
business like we we had a domain but we
didn't have you know the llc
or any hopes to have like uh a team of
people that we work with
and that's why ryan earlier was talking
about sean's like is our employee like
we don't think of people in those terms
like we're all on the same team right
and
and and and i think that early on it was
just like wow this is pretty cool like
so people are getting something from
this
and then we learn like hey maybe we can
make some money yeah well we didn't i
mean we didn't
we didn't charge for anything on our
website for the first year
that we had it i mean it was just us
putting up our essays
and it wasn't until yeah people kept
asking when are you gonna come out with
your book and i'm like well
yeah that makes sense and josh is like
yeah we're the minimalist we should
write a book on minimalism so
i mean that was really the first thing
we charged for that book we wrote in
i think it came out december 2011 is
that correct yeah
um the best sales month that it ever had
it was december 2012 13 13 sorry it was
two years later yeah
and that and so you know just to the
point of like there is no
there is no magic recipe i guess how do
you approach risk
because it seems to me that that's a
huge risk
you have these jobs where you're
comfortable where you're making a lot of
money and that's the transition question
yeah
yeah so how do you deal with that risk
when i set josh down and asked him why
the hell are you so happy
and he told me about this thing called
minimalism and introduced me to
an entire community of people who were
minimalists what i saw
was some very common sense things like
oh if i don't have a six-figure mortgage
hanging over my head
if i don't buy a new car every couple
years if i stop
racking up all this credit card debt
maybe i won't have to work
60 70 sometimes 80 hours a week
so for me minimalism the why
behind it was you know why did i want to
uh become a minimalist
when i asked myself that question how
might my life be better with
less like the one thing that really
stood out to me was was
my time i could i could reclaim some of
my time
so minimalism i wasn't like
diving into it to be this um you know
uh uh i'm going to live in a box from
i'm going to be a freaking and i'm going
to go live in a box and
uh you know live live with as little
money as possible i mean
it wasn't about doing it for the sake of
look at me look how you know altruistic
i am
like here i am giving up everything it
was more about
hey look here is i have on my plate now
and if i could find a way to give this
up
then i can reclaim some of my time and
and maybe start on a better path
so it took me about let's say about a
year
year and a half of of paying off
debt um of budgeting
eating ramen noodles and peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches which
i really wish i would have done
something different back then
it's not the healthiest diet but it was
cheap um better than carrot juice
better than carrot chips i'm pretty sure
that this is gonna be a big
fad now the carrot juice is gonna take
over yeah yeah
so so you know we didn't just quit our
jobs and start a blog that's the worst
advice anyone can give you
um it was a very slow transition in fact
i got laid off it wasn't even like i
didn't really have the choice
to be like okay now i have all my ducks
in a row
i'm gonna go ahead and quit now i'm
actually grateful i got laid off because
i don't know if i ever would have got to
that point where
i would have actually walked away i mean
probably would have but it would have
been much later
than when i got laid off in september
2012.
is that right yeah yeah yeah it sounds
like it's it's about calculated risk
so everybody should take risks and
you're gonna have to take risks in life
if you're gonna do anything
worth doing yeah absolutely i don't
think there's anything wrong with risk
as long as you're making like you said a
calculated risk so
when i got laid off thank god that i had
been going down this minimalist path
because at that point i did have uh six
months worth of bills
saved up um i had paid off a lot of my
debt i got rid of my car payment
um i i had prepared because eventually
the plan was to quit
you moved out of your big house and
rented it out to someone because you
couldn't sell it
exactly so it's so uh when
when i got laid off um yeah i mean it
i guess that wasn't really taking a risk
because i got laid off risk is kind of
risk is
what you can stomach though right it's
like everybody has a different threshold
of
what they can stomach i will i will tell
you though that like the month before i
got laid off i went to my boss and i
because i had got to a point where i
felt like okay
if i got late if i lost my job tomorrow
i can survive for at least the next six
months and try and figure out some
things to do
so i went to my boss uh the month before
i got laid off and i asked and i asked
him like hey man if i ever decide to
leave
um who who would you fill my role with
who
who would you replace me with and we
were talking and eventually he's like
you know what man he's like this
this program is working really well i
don't know if i would
if i would replace you and i'm like huh
that's a really interesting thought
isn't it
and then a month later you know i get
the text of hey ryan meet me in this
conference room where we've laid off
dozens of people before
so i mean you know when i got the text i
knew what was coming but yeah i mean
they basically
you know hired me to build a program in
the company i did that it was it was
running well
they didn't need my role anymore um but
i would not have had that conversation
with him
if i didn't already if i hadn't been
working a plan for the last
year and a half so i think that's where
risk
is okay to take like as long as you have
a plan behind it and it is a bit
calculated
um what i've learned in my life is that
i'm never gonna just fall completely
flat on my face as long as i
i do the pre-work before taking that
risk i think some risks are
are really dangerous the problem is we
think
we think most things that are risks we
treat
most things like oh my god my 401k
slipped by one tenth of one percent this
month like we have the same reaction to
that
oh my god like so as we do you know
uh i was last night we saw a coyote
walking around
like that is a much bigger risk to me
than my my 401k if that thing
was rabid and decides to attack me i
have to
trip backs and run faster than her
no i i think that um that's the problem
with with risk because we are often
treating it like
like um if something is dangerous for me
it was riskier to stay
because i saw what the outcome was when
i was those guys i aspired to be like
that's real risk that
uh going down that route you know being
fat overweight and and uh just
unhealthy in general but also being
unhappy that's
that's pretty risky too being
dissatisfied with the life you're living
like
how long are you gonna how long are you
gonna do that before you start to look
back and regret the life that you lived
and i could see that right then like i
don't regret spending
all that time in my 20s learning what i
learned and that was
i learned a whole lot that i was able to
tweeze out and pull forward but i know
if i would have continued down that path
much longer
um i i wouldn't have
been living the life that i wanted to
live and it's not
a perfect life i still feel stress and
anxiety
and and and there are times where it's
really difficult
in fact there are times it's so
difficult where i'm like man it'd be
easier to just go back and work for
someone
i don't have to make all the damn
decisions um and
and the truth is that when you look at
the aggregate
it's so much better and it's actually
less risky now
than what it was before and by the way
like staying
with where i was ultimately would have
been the biggest risk because they were
required by another company
uh by a larger telecom company that ate
them up and
and and then you know very likely
i would have been gone in that
transition back in 2014 or whatever and
then
if i wouldn't have prepared for it you
know i would have been
scrambling to try to find a similar
telecom job in
providence rhode island or something
like just trying to like
find whatever i can get to pay the bills
because i was still attached to that
lifestyle and that's a real risk
it seems like the the smartest thing
that you can do
is to develop and learn skills that
aren't going out of style anytime soon
so if you develop
becoming a better writer or if you learn
how to become a filmmaker or a
photographer
these are all things that aren't going
to go away very soon
and it's something that if you can build
something on your own
and learn how to pick up some freelance
jobs even if the economy is doing bad
even if there aren't many jobs you can
probably still pick up some work
when you press record for the first time
on a camera
you it's not you're like well i'm
getting paid to do this
um it had to do with something you're
interested in something that may be
aligned with what you wanted to do in
the future but
but it wasn't about money first and and
i think a lot of these things
for for them to to work out well
for us long term is you want to be able
to do it even if it's not
sustainable monetarily but then you can
also look to see
does anyone make money doing this is
there anyone who makes money as a
filmmaker is there anyone who makes
money as a writer
and the answer is of course yes and and
i mean
you can find someone who is you know a
a clown who i mean literally dresses up
like clowns and makes money that's what
you're passionate about then great
uh if you're passionate about teaching
horseback riding
you can find a way to make a living from
that
from from that passion or at least
somewhere that's adjacent to that
passion
for me it was a j like i wrote fiction
that was the thing i always wanted to do
and now i write a lot less fiction
because we had this whole beautiful
non-fiction round it was adjacent to
what i was already doing
and and for you i mean you started out
you were doing wedding
videography bar mitzvah dude i was just
looking at some of the old bar mitzvah
intro videos i made i saw that with the
bat on fire wasn't that like
incredible i'm like but you know what
actually i i learned and relearned
about how i approached those projects
back in the day
is that was a bar mitzvah video there
weren't high expectations but like i
used it as an opportunity
to practice color grading to learn after
effects and how to track
fire onto a baseball bat like i was like
holy cow i probably learned a lot from
that project
um but you can't just say oh it's this
is just something that's temporary i
feel like any time you're developing
your skill in your craft
you have to put yourself into it yeah i
think we all we are
we're all born with some sort of talents
but but we often
uh mistake those talents for skills a
skill is actually developed and you have
to spend time
you see so you might have a natural eye
to see
lighting or or you know the way that
that
you focus the camera or the way that you
you are filming a particular scene
you might have a natural eye for that
but what makes it beautiful
is the skill of figuring out how to do
it most effectively
i think it's the same with with anything
else any other creative endeavor
not even creative endeavors like being
in the business world like
i learned how to run a business not by
going to some class and reading about
business theory
but by opening dozens of retail stores
and
managing hundreds of employees over many
years
i messed up a lot i had mentors of my
own but it was on the job training was
much more effective than
just going to a class and and
trying to sort of learn via osmosis or
just
you can't just read what's on your page
here and then all of a sudden say well
now i know how to direct a film
it doesn't work that way it's the same
with writing a book it's the same with
with
pretty much any endeavor creative or not
yeah there are only so many
entrepreneurial books you can read
before you have to just put them down
and actually try to start a business
and you can get some good sort of best
practices from those but you still have
to implement that
in your everyday life otherwise it's
useless yeah i think it's like you get
the
the guiding wisdom and and good
mentoring from that so say if you don't
have mentors in your life that can guide
you in the right
way and say hey it's just it's not
always about the bottom line